es war einmal ein regisseur der wollte
alle interessanten geschichten aus
portugal erzählen die sich nach der
finanzkrise ereignet hat poetisch
sollten sie seien absurd aber auch war
nur wie das wusste er noch nicht da kam
ihm eine idee
wir halten diese ökonomische und
gesellschaftliche krise dort griffen die
zeitungen und das fernsehen waren voll
davon aber empfehlen muss man andere
werkzeuge benutzen und davon zu erzählen
darum habe ich die königin aller
geschichten zu hilfe geholt
miguel komisch erzählt seinen film
tausend und eine nacht wie es die
prinzessin schade tut
die sollte von ihrem ehemann getötet
werden um zu überleben erzählt sie ihm
jede nacht eine geschichte und immer im
spannendsten moment bricht sie ab
tausendundeine nacht ist ein
sechsstündiges epos erzählt in drei
filmen ein ritt durch verschiedene
themenfelder es geht um politik
erotik gerechtigkeit der regisseure
zeigen welche auswirkungen die krise auf
die menschen hat seine geschichten sind
oft schräg verlangen viel aufmerksamkeit
sind hier und da dick aufgetragen ich
denke geschichten erzählen geschichten
erfinden
das ist seit unserer kindheit die
grundlage und dinge zu vermitteln
da gibt es das kino bücher oder die
erzählungen die weitergetragen werden
von der großmutter bis zu den enkeln
so läuft das und wir brauchen die
geschichten eine der geschichten handelt
von eu politikern die über die
verteilung der gelder debattieren bis
ihnen ein ominöser zauberer ein
vielversprechendes produkt anregt von
regisseur immer wieder ins fantastische
abstruse
filmisch eigenwillig basieren sie alle
auf wahren begebenheiten
das imaginäre ist genauso teil unserer
realität
es ist eine geistige mentale realität
es geht da um sachen die zwar so nie
passiert sind die habe im imaginären
einen realen kern berührend im film sind
die halb dokumentarischen szenen etwa
wenn der fast 50 jährige ökonom seine
eigene geschichte erzählt dann verliert
er durch die krise seinen job und von
nun an geht's bergab
miguel komisch und seine versponnenen
geschichten liefern ein buntes
kaleidoskop portugals zwischen herbst
2013 und sommer 2014 eine art
krisenbewältigung die krise nicht
bewältigen
aber er kann die krise in ihren
unzähligen auswirkungen zeigen
darum ist dieser film so umfangreich
geworden wer sich auf komisches tausend
und eine nacht einlässt wird in eine
traumwelt entführt im gegensatz zu den
geschichten der fassade braucht es
geduld und sich darauf einzulassen
es lohnt sich